I just moved my slumber hello i love you
and this is the second episode of the
hair brown swap series yeah uh anybody
are if any one of you are new this is
series i'm doing with herro brown hair
branagh a mod that I got that makes him
just a little more a little more
outgoing than usual when I say run haha
and yeah that's basically what this is
just me survive in which is pretty
normal minecraft with hair brown showing
up every once in a while to do this
thing a perfect eighth perfection gonna
get some more wood when shut down the
street oh oh my fingers were in the
wrong locations in Chapman the trees are
I do not really know I'm not really know
what I'm gonna do this video but we'll
find out and also just to say thank you
guys so much do you guys have just the
first hair brown survival as is near
breaking 100 views which is the most
views I've ever gotten in a survival
series or any like just straight up game
me put me doing some gameplay so I thank
you guys a little time for that and yeah
so thank you now I want a sapling yes
hahaha yes we got some settings with
there as well so Pete you there should
be there no you're right there and you
go right there yes now let's put a tray
over here can't a bit alive but when I
was recording look pretty good so yeah
we have so many sheep and cows all right
now what do I want to do I need a pic to
have any cobblestone here cobblestone
yes I do aha probably one more take some
of the wood 222222 today let's make two
pics there we go now probably want some
sort of building ish block dirt and dirt
works well I guess foods gotcha norms
that life now and let's go explore this
mountain because this mountain looks
epic this is actually I found a dungeon
if you if you guys haven't seen the
previous video our highest just Joe go
check them out since it was my first
video ooh nope nothing it was my first
video of the series and we found a
dungeon the engine is somewhere near
here over here ah here it is career make
a better entrance to this this guy was
someone's looking nasty looks fine and
it's pretty scuttle there III just
bailed with and left this looking
terrible oh my gosh I'm gonna have to
fix this up some time but now right now
since right now we are exploring the
mountain I want to show this this here
dirt hope and good thing I brought some
a building blocks I can just build know
if they're due to do so I don't want to
waste any materials
all right we have chefs up here some
ships ships I have been certainly
neither would I know I'm shears I can't
make it use of getting your wool all
right let's turn a render distance or an
idle oak is getting some lag get a
little extra little extra sauce you got
Optifine so i can zoom in oh we got we
got a swamp over there so we can get
some slimes awesome sokol i'm debating
whether i should go get coal oh we got a
desert and we got a tiger somewhere
around here not sure I think maybe maybe
back that way ought is my house I look
so peaceful uh I wonder if I would live
jumpiness maybe maybe into that ok so i
cant want to go on a mining adventure so
back to normal I beginning some lag uh
that's why my render distance down a bit
after that so let's get this this here I
want you I don't want you oh well file
actually I want to collect some clay as
well that looks like something fun to
investigate the sub around here looks
awesome like for investigations
investigations alright art all right
this good is good write up notes oh whoa
that was some hard leg Oh County over
here wait get some snom on
and hey let's make a dive more right
here oh my god Eric don't need a waste
collar on this I think that's good i
think it was good all right who can
investigate that all right you ready for
this worthless let's go yeah well good
thing we survived why is it only dead
squid what's with the dead squid man a
little zombie just take a shelter in the
shade okay this is not going to be
productive episode at all Zack takes you
on a stand I get as much as I can from
out of the water you oh my gosh Crouch
going in the water is so slow get it got
I can get it or well whatever okay I can
manage in the water so I'll probably set
these two smelt in my house before I go
on my mining expedition out oh I'm
drowning oh gosh I didn't even realize
that all right now this is pretty
freaking epic zombie I come for your
soul oh dang zombie Oh skeleton on the
water got a journey it's got a 10 battle
of the century oh my gosh she's doc yeah
this is not good to get inland yeah no
we're not going to kill me skeleton
skeleton Yuri there we go let's get some
light in here so at least they won't
spawn they can still chill here because
protect you from the Sun but I don't
want them spawning all right let's
return to the home
now that out pretty close to do say so
myself who do the waterfall it an idea
to make like I want to make it some sort
of waterfall room I've never done that
before we go through water because we're
gonna have to make a few water Thicke's
and if it's not then people will be able
to see through oh my gosh look at that
look at how many errors I have in me
like a boss oh no that's way shop range
to one tool and I'll chop you down I
should also probably collect some seeds
and then what I'm going to want to start
a farm eventually eventually is I heroes
Amish John Besh and kind of exploring
rubbish maybe that goes down somewhere
we will find out later no yes there we
go I'm grasp this I got one season I yep
it's up sun's going down oh hello hello
my little friends go to all three day
soothes your seats that's it that's it
no more oh I should just that's not my
time this is I go over yeah I never know
when my time is so always bad meantime I
have a good amount of food nice i'm
probably gonna want to make another
furnace just put them right there do i
only have three no talk i was gonna say
if i only have three Cole this is going
to be difficult all right let's let's do
there there there and let's put half of
you and half of you half you have you
yeah that's even now should I should
even bone all this stuff we're not going
to need to the great mind expedition I
want to get some iron yes that's a good
plan i'll use the remaining coal I needs
wood I'll use the remaining coal to make
torches
alrighty that is going night time but we
can use that to our advantage what I got
what I got I got enough stuff I need a
better shovel not a better trouble just
another trouble shovel boom boom boom
there we go I wasn't taking it all right
now we can go on the grapevine an
exhibition probably just going to
staircase down a bit actually let's
check if that other place leads us
anywhere I'm gonna have to survive the
mobs to get over here no oh dang it
doesn't lead anywhere those futile
retire foods i'll kill you clear you
don't want that creeper to store follow
me no oh oh crap babe skip skip skip
skip she'll follow me creeper creeper
okay I think we're good all rights
staircase down a bit zombie I just
remembered I got to be on the watch for
Aaron hair Brian someone's please stop
still telling me how to say that I don't
know i said i might make this double
staircase once i gets mine but for now
be single since we want iron we need to
find it all while i was lucky find coal
immediately nice and so I've seen a lot
of other youtubers like so minecraft you
can see when it's dark clicks Eiffel
lighting I can kind of see when it's
dark if I like look up on my screen but
whenever I'm watching the videos even
they say oh I got to put your put put a
torch down it's annoying because this
stuff is like not there and it's like
impossible to see so i will be doing my
best I smell something really good to be
laying the torches oh my god oh you know
what you know what I'm going to come
back for this I hear a zombie
I must continue this shrub which I found
in the zombie because probably in a
cavern oh he sounds close he sent very
close no he sends up there I know
actually might be the zombie that's
above since I am NOT yeah it's just the
zombie that's above awesome it was so
good again I've no idea how long this is
pink line oh he's in lava how would the
zombie plead for that zombie I knew I
knew is the one knows up here Oh lots of
you oh oh brick oh my gosh oh my god
back back up oh my Oh creepers all right
skeleton face skeleton fight okay let's
leave than that oh my stupid creeper
I'll get you oh my god oh I'm getting
like freaking at least hidden destroy my
bed if you showed my bed oh I wasn't so
mad oh my kid haha creeper ok I want to
repair my wall oh my gosh that dumb
creeper no no no dang oh my gosh
well i think the other mobs are going to
beat a hair brown and killing me now
before but really you're just going to
fly around me or whatever before is
going to say that up no oh my gosh herro
Braun can play Slava with this mod it
gave him some extra abilities because I
was going to say teams really uh I'm
gonna watch my back for hair brown it
seems really weird at lavo would be at
this level because this is not a lob lob
I want to say working fine i could be a
outside like source like above-ground
lava pool that somehow merged with a
cavern no I'm looking for art I know
this is the most exciting thing but dang
a super creeper that was knowing at
least I lost some levels but I wasn't
that high level so doesn't matter and my
house and bad or so okay that's all that
matters I always feel like Harry runs
just going to come down my stairwell and
attack me now this mother is a thing
called a Harrow brain which all yes iron
is want mmm yeah there's a thing called
a Harrow bein which uh program which is
crafted using like blades rods redstone
like a diamond block so it is expensive
but it shows it can tell you how many
blocks way Harry Brown is from you
mm-hmm on the moon geun de you can tell
you how many blocks away hairbrained is
from you Harry Ron I'm just gonna use
them interchangeably and like if he's
within like the say 100 blocks of you it
tells you where it is so i will be
making that once i get a cachet of
diamonds I'm like a che I mean like a
diamond pick
yeah once i get a time picker probably
knees all nighter done for that I'm
dumped sword I got some irons that is
good actually I know this is going to be
mmm there's going to be quite
unprofessional but here you can see my
lap my stuff okay right 16 minutes all
right we're at 16 minutes so good thing
I just checked here i will go throw my
stuff in the smelter and then i will end
a day shoot video now eventually if i do
if i end up doing a lot of these i might
i'm going to pick you up I might just do
it where I record an hour and just split
up into like four segments of 15 minutes
so there won't be like intros or outros
and pictures and outros I just mean me
saying hello and we think but I but I'm
gonna put you there some no but I feel I
love again hmm heroin fed not be playing
his tricks what is this lava Oh
yeah I hear it I hear it so well but as
I'm saying I might not be doing that
that's if I keep doing them if right now
I'm just like doing sessions of 15
minutes oh I got to make sure that any
papers all this crap i'm going to
freaking murder you a murderer sucks off
bad no actually no no okay skeleton
skeleton shoot him shoot him Skelton yep
I want the skeleton shirt the creeper he
is preaching up why this would
inaccurate no no ah dang it on a music
disc well I'll wreck him oh you're
burnin heard off from while I found me
some cold how pick that up later since I
need in this video alright but for now
we will of intros and outros and that's
get that squid is just drowned in water
alright well I'll end it on top of my
house cool right a little bit like I
hope you all enjoy this second episode
axel I will eat while facing you guys
let's hope you enjoy this second episode
of wow there's no eating animation I
think it turned that off because I'm
pretty sure there is an even animation
oh well I hope you all enjoyed this
second episode we did make sure you
leave like all that creepers are going
to get wrecked so good make sure you
leave it a like comment subscribe and if
you really really really enjoyed it I'll
leave it a favorite that would be very
appreciated again mmm hello and I'm
prestige here that's what I'm talking
about I'm prestige ah as I said
subscribe
and excited just of all time oh yeah the
epic epic of them all deuces